the One Piece manga just absolutely
crushed our souls by revealing the near
conclusion of the epic battle between
monkey the Garb and the former Admiral
aokiji on pilot islands and I don't
think that anyone expected the final
result because in a shocking turn of
events GARP was stabbed straight through
his gut and then basically defeated by
okiji and the other members of the
Blackbeard Pirates which might now lead
to guard being captured or even worse
being killed in this battle with his
former students and on top of that we of
course also got even more insane powers
from Garb the Blackbeard crew and a
deeper look into the future
possibilities for aokiji in the story
but first can we please just take a
moment to appreciate just what an
absolute monster GARP is as a fighter
because in this chapter he is
essentially fighting half of an entire
yonko crew including an admiral level
character in aokiji and he is still
dealing massive damage to everyone in
fact he nearly killed the massive San
Juan Wolf by cash usually tossing the
mountain of a man into the ocean then he
blocks a flaming alcohol Blast by
grabbing those random Pirates and then
he even has the audacity to toss the
Flaming bodies around the town like they
were firecrackers on Independence Day
but what makes this even more impressive
is that he's doing all of this while at
the same time protecting the escaped
prisoners and the other members of Sword
while they flee the islands by the way
I'm loving the focus on his raw power
during his fights and even during some
of the flashback in this chapter I
personally feel like insane hockey and
devil fruits have kind of taken over the
series so much it's really nice to just
see one man popping off with his fists
although he's technically not doing all
of this by himself because Kobe helmepo
and rear Admiral gurus are also all
remain on the island to allow the others
to escape and honestly though I'm pretty
sure that guard would probably have done
better by himself honestly because while
Kobe is tricked into trying to rescue a
random woman the invisible swordsman
shidu appears and is about to stab the
Marine Captain however we then get to
see just how much Garb actually cares
about Kobe because he throws himself in
the way and gets stabbed through the
stomach just like Whitebeard basically
did back at Marine Fort and uh let me
tell you this moment when I read this
literally made my heart skip a beat not
only because of the shock factor of the
scene itself but also seeing Garb throw
himself around to protect someone else
is just such a Monumental change
compared to his actions back at
marineford if you know what I mean
because if you remember GARP also really
cared a lot about Ace because he helped
to raise him as a child well if you
consider dropping him off with a bunch
of Bandits solid parenting I guess but
anyways to put all of this into
perspective Garb knew Ace for 20 plus
years Ace's father Goldie Roger even
trusted Garb personally to take care of
his child and ensure that he lived and
still none of that was enough to make
Garb rescue Ace or help Luffy which is
why it is so shocking to see him
completely put his life on the line to
rescue Kobe here though we have to be
fair if he probably wanted to put his
life on the line at marineford just put
his work first but I mean wow just how
much does he care still for this
pink-haired kit and we'll discuss more
of that in just a bit but first off GARP
isn't quite out of the battle just yet
in fact he immediately slams Studio's
heads into the pavement which again
awesome moment and while there's still
some serious damage once again to the
former Jailer shirio gets the last laugh
because he knows that GARP has taken a
massive blow here and it's honestly
pretty lucky I think for the Blackbeard
pirates that Kobe was still on the
island here because without this
deception that put Kobe in serious
danger I do think that Garb probably
would have definitely won this fight am
I right which again what a true chat of
a character and while this battle
continues GARP is weakened but he still
has to face the massive threat of aokiji
and the rest of the Blackman at pirates
in fact at the end of the chapter we
even see GARP bleeding on the ground
which leaves me thinking that he might
be defeated very soon or we could of
course also see him unleash his true
power though honestly what we've seen so
far was already crazy enough but we'll
see by the way Kobe is still there to
help him but I don't really think that
Kobe can take on all of these enemies by
himself at the moment however since GARP
already sacrificed himself to save Kobe
I could see him take it one step further
and do something crazy like launching
Kobe of the islands and if that were to
be the case that would leave GARP in a
very tough situation indeed which I
honestly don't think he would escape
from and if that should happen it would
basically leave us with two incredibly
interesting options for what will happen
to Luffy's grandfather after this the
first and honestly most likely option is
that GARP might be captured by the
Blackbeard Pirates but seriously good
luck keeping this Powerhouse hostage
c-stone will probably not work on him
but maybe aokiji will freeze him or some
something to keep him under control
anyways this option is pretty likely to
occur because in this chapter we even
were told that his cross skill Bounty is
three billion berries which is actually
an extremely interesting number because
we also learned that this is the exact
same amount as most marine Admirals and
you might even remember that this is
exactly equal to Luffy's current Bounty
as well so so I guess this might be
oda's way of telling us that Luffy's
only now catching up to garb's level or
maybe GARP is on Luffy's level well
whatever way you want to look at it I'm
not too sure but if GARP is captured
then he could actually be used as a
bargaining chip that Blackbeard
described back in chapter 1080 here
because remember the evil yonko's whole
plan for capturing Kobe in the first
place was to try to Ransom him to the
world government in exchange for pirate
Islands being officially recognized as a
kingdom by the world governments and
while that ultimately wouldn't work with
Kobe because he is a member of sort GARP
might be the perfect Marine to hold for
ransom in his stats that's because he's
basically the most famous Marine in the
world and he is called the literal hero
of the Marine so if the world government
didn't do anything in their power they
could to rescue him it could turn into a
disaster that could cause even more
people to lose faith in their leadership
than already have recently but let's say
that Blackbeard didn't want to deal with
GARP here an even more incredible option
might be that he could also turn GARP
over to the Cross guilds to turn in that
juicy Bounty and it doesn't even take
too much speculation to think that this
could lead us to a reverse sort of
marine forts what I mean by that is that
we could have a situation where instead
of the Marines executing a pirate like
they did with Ace we instead could have
Pirates executing a famous marine and I
mean can you just imagine the chaos
something like this might cause with
buggy broadcasting the show to the
entire world it would be absolutely
insane and once again Luffy's family on
the line of course which of course
brings us to an even bigger question
would Luffy come to safeguard I mean
with all the crazy events going on on
Egghead Island right now it is really
hard to say but with Ace already dead
it's kind of hard to see Luffy not
trying everything to save his
grandfather and yes while it's clearly
still too early to really speculate any
more than that possibility the other
option for garb's future is that he
simply dies during this battle here on
pirate Islands while I personally don't
really see that happening right now you
can't say that Garb doesn't have a
ridiculous number of deathflex on him I
mean let's let's count him shall we
first of all he's a likable older Mentor
type character with no super clear role
in the story right now except maybe to
inspire people does that uh remind you
of anyone plus he is the family of the
main protagonist and we've just seen him
save one of his favorite students while
battling another former student and
really if this is not on your
stereotypical checklist of Shonen death
Flags then I will really don't know what
would make it on that but if we're
taking this option actually seriously
then we do have to consider what would
be the purpose of GARP dying here on
pirate Islands would it be just to
inspire Kobe I mean he did shout out
that Justice would Prevail but as a
certain pink flamingo once told us
Justice is determined by whoever wins
the war and so while inspiring Kobe is
certainly possible although a little
weird since we haven't really seen Garb
and Kobe interact a ton in the story
there's actually one other option that
was hinted at during all the flashback
scenes in this chapter and that's
because in this chapter we do see that
GARP developed a deep bond with aokiji
as well and the former Admiral truly
respected his former teacher and of
course we'll discuss more about their
relationship in just a second and what
it means for aokiji's fuja roll but for
now I wonder if garb's the feature is
actually a massive red herring for us
and Oda is just really trying to trick
us all you see back in chapter 1080 some
members of Blackbeard's crew here were
suspicious of the the former Admiral
joining their ranks however killing Garb
would definitely show them once and for
all that aokiji is on their side so
could Garb really be doing all of this
on purpose to help aokiji with some sort
of secret important mission to
infiltrate Blackbeard's base if you want
to think about it that way it's kind of
like in Harry Potter when Professor
Snape killed Dumbledore to gain the bad
guy's trust although to be perfectly
honest I don't really know how willing
Garb would be to sacrifice himself since
he wasn't already dying as Dumbledore
was but while we don't know if Garb
still trusts aokiji this much he
certainly trusts Kobe to be the future
of the Marines and I've always wondered
why exactly that is I mean is it as
simple as GARP seeing something special
in the way that Kobe thinks about
Justice I mean Kobe will do whatever is
right no matter situation we saw an
example of this at marineford when he
stood up to a kainu and even recently in
chapter 1080 when we saw that he was
perfectly happy to wear work with this
ghost girl if it meant that he could
continue his duty or if it isn't just
Kobe's strong sense of fair Justice
another option is that Garb actually
knows something very special about Kobe
that we don't for instance we don't
really know Kobe's family lineage we
just met him on this random boat in
Chapter 2 of the story but maybe GARP
does know more about Kobe and he has a
clue about some future special ability
that Kobe has inside of him I mean
honestly at this point it's certainly
possible considering all the new family
Dynamics surrounding other characters
with interesting hair colors that we've
been getting in recent chapters just see
Vivian Shanks but whatever garb's reason
for believing in Kobe I can't imagine
that the young Marine doesn't survive
this battle so I'm pretty sure we'll
learn more about his super important
role in the story very soon and by the
way if you want to make sure to hear all
about the changes Kobe will bring to the
world in future chapter reviews make
sure to subscribe to the channel for
more one-piece content just like this
but now just like Kobe these slime balls
are also going to to play Vital roles in
the final Saga and in this chapter we
once again see that the theme of the
Blackbeard Pirates is to win using
tricks and deception I mean come on we
saw I didn't pull down and at Marine for
it and here once again when they tricked
Kobe which led to GARP being stabbed
again in fact we will undoubtedly see
some sort of devious scheme when they
face the straw hats I mean you can be
very sure of that for example they could
kidnap a crew member looking at you miss
archaeologist or maybe somehow they
actually managed to get a Trader on the
crew which is kind of hard to imagine
but who knows whatever it really is one
nearly certain thing is that Zoro will
also have to deal with shiru's
dishonorable fighting style especially
considering his famous quote back during
his duel with mihawk that scars on the
back are a swordsman's greatest shame
and in this chapter we also get a better
look at the powers of vasco's shots if
you remember it was recently revealed
that he ate the liquor fruit and we just
now saw him spit out a steam of
flammable alcohol that he somehow set on
fire however what I personally thought
was even more impressive were these
truly massive arms that avalo Pizarro
shot out of the island using his insane
devil fruit I mean seriously what's the
deal with all these devil fruits they do
see you incredibly overpowered given
that everyone in the one piece World
basically lives on an island though I do
have to say that none of these was
nearly as impressive as aokiji's Mastery
of his devil fruit and especially his
really overpowered hockey that we
finally got to see in this chapter and
really I don't care about the powers who
are definitely gonna say that guard was
already weak which yeah fair enough but
aokiji's hockey powered fists still
absolutely send GARP flying so kudos to
this ice cold dude here and even though
aokiji got thrown back as well obviously
that's still incredibly impressive
considering that GARP is likely one of
the strongest hockey users in the entire
world now that's not to say though of
course that aokiji shouldn't be thank
thankful to guard because he would have
likely never gotten to this level of
power without garb's training from the
past and that's because in this chapter
we finally also see in flashbacks that
GARP actually personally trained and
eventually befriended a young kuzan
before my Admiral even trained so hard
that he could beat up those giant old
warships on the same level as Garb
himself but what's even more impressive
is that GARP seemed to somehow consider
aokiji a friend that he could talk to
about his problems for instance he
mentions that his grandson Luffy wants
to become a pirate and that his son
Dragon started the Revolutionary Army
wait hold on that this kind of
incredibly important right I mean if
dragon is actually garp's son and not
just his son-in-law that could mean that
well let's let's save that discussion
for another day the one thing that is
still really bugging me is that Oda is
really trying to make us believe here
that aokiji truly wants to work for
Blackbeard and is evil even though
aokiji's Justice model is lazy Justice
to me he's always seemed like the guy
who wants to really do the right thing
but he was still searching for answers
and to speculate on what he might
actually do in the future let's briefly
go over his character Arc so far in the
story in case you don't remember it all
started back in chapter 321 during this
fight Luffy challenged him to a
one-on-one duel so that the Admiral
wouldn't go after the rest of his crew
and even though aokiji at that point
easily defeated Luffy aokiji didn't kill
destroyed captain and he honored the
terms of the Duel By not chasing after
the crew then we had a boatload of
information about the icy Admiral during
Robin's flashback where aokiji was part
of the group that destroyed the
scholarly island of Ohara and aokiji
even appeared to go so far as to kill
his friend Saul after the giant had
betrayed the Marines but then in the
very same chapter aokiji seemed to
recognize that Saul desperately wanted
to save Robin for some reason and he
decided to let Robin go instead of
killing her like he was ordered to and
to me this means that he clearly
inherited Saul's dream that Robin should
live this idea is further supported by
Robin and aokiji's talk outside the
banquet after Ennis Lobby he tells her
that maybe she can answer the question
of why Saul wanted her to live so really
he seems to be searching for answers
that he can't discover for himself plus
later on we find out that aokiji didn't
actually kill Saul so there seems to be
a lot of internal conflict for what
aokiji truly believes in fact allegedly
at least after the time skip aokiji left
the Marines because he didn't want to
work under the bloodthirsty akinu we
next see him in chapter 698 when he
actually saves vice admiral smoker from
being killed by the warlock or Flamingo
and really this scene shows us that
aokiji still is a good person who cares
about his friends and the overall safety
of the world which honestly to me makes
it just impossible to believe that he is
truly evil now and joined the black Bay
Pirates just to take over the world I
mean Oda is trying to sell it really
hard but I just don't buy it but then
again maybe he just really wanted to be
a pirate to have a fun time Crossing
back to booze with the boys like we saw
in chapter 1080 who knows and honestly
it kind of makes me really curious to
think about out what aokita's Journey
might have looked like if he had decided
to be a pirate from the beginning I mean
with his powers he would absolutely be a
massive threat to become a yonko or even
find the one piece and so I went ahead
and thought out exactly how his pirate
adventure and that of the other Admirals
could have gone in this video right here
which you can watch right now if you
want to thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next chapter